Google great yeah so I just want to take
a moment to thank the conference
organizers for inviting me and also for
throwing this together digitally it's
really great that this can still happen
and honestly I think it's been going
super well maybe I just jinxed myself
but I suppose so
yeah I'm Julian Kelly I'm one of the
hardware team leads at Google at quantum
and I'm gonna be talking about a
resource of quantum supremacy using a
programmable superconducting processor
so I want to talk about this experiment
really framed as a system performance
benchmark and then I'm gonna talk about
some of the things we did to actually
get the experiment to work so I'll talk
about the hardware the Sycamore
processor and the stack then I'm gonna
talk in depth a little bit about
software calibration and how we got that
to work so we'd like to show this plot
that demonstrates our Google hardware
development path and we'd like to
understand the state of a hardware both
by looking at the number of cuba's but
also the limiting error rate at the
devices and what you can see here is
that you have an insufficient number of
qubits or if you have a lot of qubits
what the error rates are high
essentially everything that you can do
is classically simulate a hole it's this
really interesting point right here if
you have sufficient kiba's with
sufficiently low error rates you can
demonstrate climate supremacy what's
important about this is that this is
really just a milestone order on our
development trajectory we're planning to
investigate niskin near from
applications but eventually build
towards the useful error correcting
quantity so in 2012 john prescott puts
worthless notion of quanta supremacy
when we will be able to perform tasks
with controlled quantum systems by going
beyond what can be achieved with
ordinary digital computers and as
someone who works on a hardware this is
my favorite quote in that paper where he
s is controlling larger scale quantum
systems merely really really hard
or is it ridiculously hard and after
this we get to conclude that it is
merely really really hard so here's the
article um we have a whole bunch of
authors on here and this a bit more fun
way of looking at them here's a picture
of our team so what does the COS of
frequency experiment and again I want I
want to post this related benchmark of
understanding the hardware so when we do
benchmarking
we want to be able to measure a
component air rates that are predictive
of algorithm performance so for example
if we measure the single cubic days to
keep it gauge measurements it sure would
be great if we could then compose an
algorithm that would look something like
this and say that the fidelity day
algorithm is a product of the case and
the product um this isn't something that
you take for granted
experimental quantum computing is hard
it's really really hard and in fact we
just heard an hour talk about how you
can't just assume that this is the case
this is something it's a little bit
tricky and subtle and so in order to get
this to work you need to go to hardware
and you really need a sophisticated
understanding of how your hardware
actually performs so we want to put this
to the test in the quantum supremacy
experiment or basically benchmark deploy
algorithm performance and we're
comparing it to this model from the
component arrow race and see if we can
get these to mash up and see if we can
really understand the system so this is
the processor that we're doing it on
it's just a sycamore device it has 54
qubits and 88 couplers the actual device
if you said one broken key bit but you
know that's that's experimental physics
room so here are the results of
benchmarking the Sycamore device and in
here we're looking at an integrated
histogram or ECG EF and I'm plotting the
the poly air race and also the mesh
repairs and here is this these
distributions summarized in a table
we're gonna look at the single qubit
arrays of to QB erase the two qubit
arrays per cycles it's kind of similar
to what controls is talking about when
we do our benchmarking me to compose a
cycle of the to Cuba gate into single
qubit gates we also look at the readout
error and importantly what we're really
interested in this is simultaneous
operations so here the single qubit gate
areas in the poly representation work
for one six percent 153 qubits are
running at the same time to keep it gay
there's or 0.62 and the readout here is
around 320 percent we also have that
isolated plotted here but honestly this
is a bit more of a like curiosity in
some sense because this is what's
predictive for running algorithms
so what we're claiming is that we'd like
to be able to predict these large
algorithm performance based on some
distributions so this is what it looks
like mapped across the physical device
so each one of these X's is a qubit and
the color corresponds to a single qubit
error rate and these two boxes in
between represent the error at the
cheese cookies
so the the circuit that we're actually
going to run this across the entropy
benchmarking circuit and the idea is
that we're going to sample the output of
a pseudorandom quantum circuit and some
of the features that you notice of this
is that it has a very dense structures
it's highly parallel so for example
there's many single qubit gates
happening at the same time and then
there's also many two qubit gate 7 at
the same time and we're going to go to a
high circuit depth and and then
basically at the end of it we're going
to assign some algorithm fidelity using
a classical code simulation this is for
the circuits that we've chosen to be
easy and verifiable to understand our
system so this is what the component
model looks like so again we're gonna
say that the fidelity should basically
be a product of the case in the readout
and you know taken from this map and
hang on exactly what you keep it so
you're going to use and in your circuit
and we're gonna fix the the depth at 14
cycles of these single and two qubit
gates and then we're going to scale the
number of keys what we see is that
there's a model prediction it looks like
this basically expect an exponential
decay that you'd expect from multiplying
civilities and it's pretty uniform
because the device is performed pretty
consistently so we actually go compared
to the experiment we compare the model
to the full story and we also have these
simplified circuits that surgery with
about yesterday and we essentially what
we see is that the full model matches
the simplified prediction matches of
prediction from the component error
rates and this is working over 16
decades of Hilbert space which is pretty
enormous so what's important about this
is this is saying that we understand our
system and if there's no new kind of
crazy features of quantum mechanics
creeping in these hybrid higher higher
dimensional spaces so why did this
actually work experimental e as we heard
before crosstalk is a really important
consideration we've done a lot of
engineering to make the cross cyclone
the device and use some increased
mitigation strategies the calibrations
that we do are representative of the
algorithm that we want to perform which
isn't pretty and also these random story
is depolarized systematic errors which
is another thing that joel touched him
on the floor good they don't accumulate
an uncontrolled way and it's based off
these confidence in these error models
of thinkin when we can detonate these
predictions into the unstimulated wakana
supremacy space and say we believe that
we got point two percent fidelity and at
to a depth of say 20 cycles suspension
three cubits
okay with that being said I want to go
in and talk a bit about the actual hard
way and how we got these results so this
is the state of our of our devices in
2015 here's an example of a nine qubit
linear chain I'm particularly fond of
this device because I did my PhD thesis
on it and one of the things that you
know if you look at this and you're
thinking about scaling it up it seems to
be a bit tricky you see that the control
wiring takes up time from like half of
the chip if you want to go to two
dimensions where do you put to keep its
how do you get to fifty so one of the
important technologies we introduced in
the last member of years are the
scalable designs using flip chip bonding
the basic idea is instead of having a
one ship we partition this across to
your friendships so we take the qubits
we put them on to keep a chip that gives
us room to make a two-dimensional array
and then we have a control chip that
brings some control wirings we then
electrically and mechanically stitch
these chips together using Indian box
office here's an image of what one of
these prototype devices like from a few
years ago here there's just six chips on
this cubed device here and you can see
every one of these little dots is some
Indian bump ons then we have a control
chip here that has wiring coming in to
control the devices we then stack them
together and we get this assembly that
looks something like this these two
chips electrically connected so we take
this assembly we put it into our package
where we have a circuit board where we
make electrical connections to the chip
this goes inside some electromagnetic
and infrared shielding we then bring in
an additional about 100 or more coax
connectors to make connections to the to
control the qubits this package then
goes into the bottom of the dilution
refrigerator at around ten millikelvin
and then we have lots of wiring going up
to room temperature so at room
temperature we have custom scalable
electronic so easy to generate our
control signals here is an example of
one of our boards we give the name Heron
board it's got eight analog outputs and
these can use to generate 0 to 400
megahertz arbitrary waveforms and then
we also have the option of up converting
them to 60 cookers to drive to the
qubits directly um this is just one card
so we can also fill out say a creatively
something like
and then we actually used about for
these crates of powerful Sookie more
device and here's all that the coax
going into a to manipulative processor
so the very first large 2d chip that we
made was a Bristlecone device and decide
72 qubits it looked something like this
and the keypad geometry each one of
these X's represents two cubed where
they come together represents a couple
in through the qubits where you can get
entanglement or interactions so one of
the most fundamental things to
understand when you're evaluating a
quantum computer architecture is to
understand how the coupling between the
qubits is done so in this particular
device we use a fixed capacitance and
always on coupling and here's an example
from an older device where you see that
we get that by basically putting the
qubits close to each other in the
essential capacitance this is the great
it's a simple proven technology a number
of years ago where we'll tell you about
99.5%
seesee and the idea is it works by the
capacitance is always on but we can
modulate the coupling by using tunable
qubits and changing the detuning between
them to turn on those so one of the
system considerations that comes out of
this is that what this means is that
when you're doing interactions onto cue
but it's the their neighbors because
they also have a fixed coupling you have
to perform echo sequences on them to
cancel any straight coupling
interactions and this this leads to
imperfect parallelism of the gates you
can employ so if you have a array of
qubits like this for make if it's a dog
we're doing say cz gates between them
these these qubits in the gray are
actually forced to idle with echo
operations and that can't be doing
something so one of the advances that we
introduced in sycamore was this tunable
coupling Orca texture and what we found
is that being able to turn the cube in
directions on and off are really helpful
for making this system overall look
better and we've done this in the
scalable to the architecture we
essentially introduced an extra a
tunable coupler device to mediate the
interactions for you to do this so what
does that actually look like an
experimental data so here's here's a
nice plot of that we're gonna take these
two qubits one let's call them QA and QB
and we're gonna put them at the same
frequency like they're exactly on
resonance with each other and then we're
gonna sweep the ocular bias which
modulate
a couple new 20 cubits what happens is
that if we excite one and there's some
coupling will see this excitation will
swap back and forth between the qubits
in via as long as they're on residents
with each other and then if we change a
couple of value over here we can turn on
a much stronger coupling that successive
make the excitation swap back and forth
look pretty quickly well it's very
important it's right in between we
actually have a zero cross today and the
coupling and we can essentially put the
Cubist's perfectly honest with each
other and have the excitation stay in
one qubit number one thing I want to
point out is that this is an
experimental data actually someone from
our team put this on a slide and I
didn't really believe it I I made them
label it let me tell you that when I
joined the field number of years ago
superconducting qubits were making data
looked anything like this so this is fun
to see these types of things come out of
our more recent devices of course this
is the the stick and water processor
that we that we developed that uses this
technology so with everything you really
need to evaluate the trade-offs thinking
about making changes of the hardware and
I want to talk about the pros and cons
that ins tunable coupler so as I touched
on before this coupling off removes
Strait coupling and you get kind of
natively a 2x increasing potential
parallelism from Kate's by doing this so
for example I'm first look on before we
can have some maximum gate density looks
like this but because if against
interactions off we don't have to do
these echo operations if we can actually
have every single gate participating in
its own to qvg at the same time
additionally the coupler makes it easier
to access a wider gate set so we can
make CZK swap gates I swap gauge square
device for Bates and in fact we can make
everything in between so if we look at
this 2d phase space of I swap kind of
gates and conditional phase gates we
have a recent publication where you can
actually access all of these with high
fidelity and these sort of I swap light
gates with a little bit of conditional
phase that's what we're using in the
consequences so of course with
everything there's some cons about
introducing something like this so when
we add another element we're opening
ourselves up to added decoherence in
addition noise strength a constant
additional two control lines per kiba
which is really nothing to scoff at
that's actually expensive and something
not to be overlooked is that this
increases the calibrate
in complexity for our devices so you can
only measure the coupler indirectly but
you really need to have a good control
over in order to implement high fidelity
operations so this brings me to our
quantum hardware principle is how we
think about this decision design that we
round that we're doing so we we
recognize that system performance is
really what's key for a logarithm so
that means we care about things like
simultaneous performance parallelism the
accessible gate set and we recognize
that things like coherence times and
isolated gate Fidelity's are only part
of the story again this also goes to the
point that joel was making in the
previous phone so our strategy is to
make highly configurable processors with
tunability strategically introduced so
in Chris Lacan that I mentioned will
keep its tune while qubits or something
that we've been working with for a very
long time in our team basically the
whole history of it and then in Sycamore
we're also introducing tunable couplers
which is also something we've been
looking at for a long time but now
they're sort of deployed at scale
what this leaves us with is a very
complex system we have a control
challenge and what we're going to do is
we're really just going to embrace his
control challenge both with software and
so actually artificial intelligence so
now I'm going to talk a bit about how we
actually calibrate our processors and
get them to so the process of
calibration is learning to execute
quantum logic and really that this is
taking a physical device like a physics
experiment and getting it to a point
where you can execute single to qubit
gates measurements kind of whatever you
want you can program it and some of the
challenges of this is that kiba's cannot
be controlled identically so some of
that can come from for example in how
much an 80 cubic parameters we
manufacture qubits are not identical but
really this is actually a general
property of quantum systems their analog
any in homogeneity in your control
system also means that you have to
grapple with this additionally these
optimized breakers can drift in time but
we learned these control parameters by
carefully sequencing we strap the
experiments so for example if you go
into the lab you may do some
spectroscopy you have to do that before
you say to a Rabi flopping experiment
and there's a whole bunch of things that
you have to do in between the free to
your say two qubit gate calibration and
what we find is that we're calibrating
something like 10 to the 10 of the 2
parameters per qubit to get up the
performer
levels that we that were happy with so
what we use for this is this idea called
optimist which is essentially an
artificial intelligence for calibrating
climate processors and the way to
understand this is that these
calibration experiments they have a
common structure so every logic Springs
are you want to perform there's some
prerequisite experiment so you have to
do first is to sort of this
bootstrapping thing I talked about where
you want to do spectroscopy before you
do Rabi flopping and then each one of
these experiments has some waveform
sequence to learn a control parameter so
for Rabi flopping you might do some
drive on the XY drive and then read out
the state of the qubit and then you can
for example fix the amplitude and sweep
the duration this gives you some data
where you see the population that keep
it oscillating between 0 & 1 and then we
can use an analysis function that looks
at this data and says oh yes to get a PI
pulse we're going to use a duration of
say 10 nanoseconds they don't we do is
we basically take that parameter we
update a database that we have of our
control parameters and say this qubit
needs a pipe illustration 10 nanoseconds
so all of this represents one
calibration and we basically say this is
now going to be a node in a graph and
wherever connect these nodes by directed
edges so these directed edges capture
this bootstrapping idea word we need to
perform these yellow calibrations before
we perform this blue calibration which
needs to happen before we perform the
screening operation and essentially what
we can do now is we can reduce this
calibration problem into a graph
traversal algorithm we can fly so this
is what a calibration graph looks like
for Sycamore um actually just for two
qubits and say that we calibrate all
kinds of things so we start over here
there's some really fundamental device
parameters we explore first we then move
on to calibrating things like single
qubit gates readout we go back and forth
focus some more device parameters and
end up fine-tuning readout and
fine-tuning ret cubic eighty
calibrations interview every one of
these nodes represents an experiment and
the analysis associated with it and we
have to get through thousands of these
calibrations in order to get a sycamore
processors working with high fidelity so
I'm gonna step through some of the
calibrations that we do mostly because
it's kind of fun to look at so here's an
example of the really kind of
rudimentary hello qubit Rabi
oscillations we do early on in the graph
and you see that there's some
oscillation here we pick off this point
to say this is a coarse high amplitude
and this is plotted for all three of us
using our processors as our favorite and
broken Cuba dismissive maker because an
example of what calibrating readout
looks like we call these readout clubs
where you compare single shots of we've
repeated zero that one state and then we
can draw this discrimination line that
tells us when we get a shot do we label
it and see where we live one and then
this is what it looks like a CrossFit of
us and then this is how we calibrate our
two-qubit I swap like interactions we're
essentially assistant Rabi flopping
between jookiba's where we pass the
expectation formed the other we just
identify this maximum and you can do
that for all the eighty-six couplers
have you seen experiments were plotted
between the capacitor so now it's a
particularly sophisticated calibration
that we do that has to do the two qubit
gates so I'm just going to walk you
through this a little bit so right here
this - green line is the two qubit X CDs
cycle fidelity where the the qubits are
operating in isolation and then if we
then go say instead of just operating
two cavus we're trying to operate the
entire device we then get this blue
curve all we see is we've got like a
pretty significant degradation
performance again this is an integrated
histogram and we're looking at the
pollinator on the x axis we get it come
at disappointing error cycles about 1%
um and it turns out that the solution of
this this essentially just calibrate
instead of calculating isolation and
operating in parallel calibrating
parallel and what the difference
actually is is that we have this model
right here where we see this one one of
these parameters is significantly
different if we're looking at the
difference between um the the isolated
versus parallel calibration this one
really sticks out what we see if we get
something like a 5 degree control angle
shift and what is happening here is that
essentially the difference between
isolated and parallel gates is that
we're having these single qubit Z frame
updates that sandwich is to keep it
acute and um this is actually pretty
simple to just compensate for in
software and that's that's effectively
what we're doing in this parallel
calibration point out is that
this is only about say a medians 5
degrees phase shift which is great
because if you imagine you know just
operating two qubits at a time versus
operating say 22 cubic gates at the same
time we're only incurring like a 5
degree control angle penalty which is
great and makes it a lot easier to
actually handle this type of Correction
software um what we actually get for
doing this as we improve that error per
to giving a term about 0.2% which really
doesn't sound like a huge amount but if
you look at how that affects the final
experimental fidelity you look at the
ratio fidelity so we would have gone
erased it to the whole 432 qubit gates
that we actually execute the algorithm
and that's like a factor of over 22.4 x
and Sergey actually mentioned yesterday
that not having a factor like this would
significantly degree the types of claims
that we can make okay so the purpose of
optimized this allows us to distill
experimental knowledge is into code that
can be deployed we use this for
calibration but we also used it for if
communication this is an abler the
performance that we needed for qualm
supremacy and we use this on all of our
google processors for both hardware and
also for algorithm development so I want
to talk about just another interesting
and tricky calibration problem which is
the frequency placement problem and how
we solve that so as I mentioned before
we use tunable kiba's and these are
great and they're also tricky because
they're highly configurable and what
that means is that we can actually
choose for each qubit what frequency we
want to operate at for single qubit
gates both frequency won't operate a
particular frequency want operator
readout
so if we imagine and we have this
sycamore processor we take these two
qubits we can choose what the the space
doing things around the one state is for
single qubit gates for each of them then
we can also choose where we want them to
be interacting to each other um we have
something like 100 meaningful frequency
choices per qubit and that means our
solution space is actually quite large
since they'd like a hundred to the 4n
right instant number of qubits because
we have four frequencies to choose bird
and that gives you something like 10 to
the 3 9 18 for Sycamore which is a
little bit ridiculous ridiculous if
people are especially I think in the
context that works at about exploring
Hilbert spaces at like 10 and 16
so there's many experimental constraints
to consider here and we're picking
frequency's so we care about the
coherence of the qubits the straight
coupling between them pulses torsion and
all of these considerations are highly
frequency dependent so what we've done
to actually deal with this is to develop
a custom snake optimization algorithm
out snake optimization algorithm that
allows us to maximize the system
performance and we've got a white paper
we're going to talk about this a little
more detail on the preparation so oh
that is nice but let's try and visualize
what this actually means what are the
inputs and the outputs of this so um if
we take the ideal case where again this
is a representation of the processor
each one of these pixels represents the
the qubit frequency if we don't have any
constraints of problems degenerate and a
public-key us with the same frequency
we're just going to make it this gray
color now if we consider for example
that there is de phasing always reflects
noise on the qubits
then what we would like to be able to do
is push it to keep us to the perplexed
instance of the points so these are
tunable transform so it's a particular
frequency that we can push them to that
makes them insensitive to that and what
you see is that there's in homogeneity
in the qubits like there's the processor
from fabrication where the parameters
are a little bit different this flux
insensitive frequency but otherwise that
the qubits are all pretty similar then
we can apply for example a constraint of
now we're gonna also worried about pulse
distortions and what that does is that
it tries to minimize the difference in
frequency between neighbors so that they
don't have to move as far to get to it
at angular point and the effect of that
is this pulls this entire region of the
device closer to this sort of
homogeneity if we then introduce nearest
neighbor person a coupling that
penalizes gave us being perfectly on
residence with each other and we see
this sort of checkerboard pattern emerge
which is really cool because that
matches your intuition and if we also
include NextEra Sabre parasitic coupling
that we actually get an even more
splitting up this checkerboard pattern
and then lastly we can introduce things
like worrying about two-level state
coherence defect stores store microwaves
most of our processor and he gets them
configuration that comes out of the
optimizer it looks like this so this is
great you know it's a nice story there's
pretty pictures but how does this
actually perform is it actually useful
or is it all talk
so the way that we're going to test it
I think we've lost Julian or we lost a
screen share anyway
and he's awesome I think is also muted
hello Julian are you out there
alright is that Jimmy uh-huh we got you
back
okay I'm gonna share my screen again
share your screen again yeah to ask the
questions already the questions yeah
about two or three minutes to actually
get yeah and it's amusing that I
definitely cursed myself in the
beginning of this talk so you know what
are you gonna do um so I just want to
wrap up by talking about how we actually
benchmark this to see how it's working
so we're gonna use a cross country
benchmarking xeb is the to keep it gay
to single candidates for each pair of
qubits what we're gonna do is we're
gonna optimize the frequencies with our
custom optimizer on the device we're
then going to calibrate all the gates
and they were going to benchmark them
and see our performance
so as we're working towards prepping for
the supremacy experiment and getting the
second word processor online we had a
very talented expert human working on
solving this frequency optimization
problem and this is the distribution
that they were able to get by working on
this carefully over a matter of weeks
with their intuition and experimental
feedback and we deployed our first model
and we saw that it was it was a bit
disappointing we're getting a cycle air
above 1% and there's a significant gap
between the model minima but at that
point with this framework were able to
go back I find two neural models I
understand how to actually weight the
errors and the cost functions from each
other and employ a new model on this
model actually worked better than what
the human was able to do however what
the what they had been working with and
I want to point out that this is sort of
like weeks of human time versus a
seconds of optimizer time and in fact we
can then continue to do this and
continue to improve the performance and
make the device work even better and
this is an important enabler of getting
the performance for demonstrating
kwang-soo Penn State so in conclusion
we recently completed this coin
supremacy experiment it really should be
seen I think well I'm biased because I
do hard work as a hardware system
performance benchmark and we've been
able to show low simultaneous areas
across all the qubits and operations
we've been able to run a 53 cubed
algorithm where the performance was
predicted by these component error rates
and we're really doing this as a
milestone towards a useful computer we
talked about a number of hardware
advances to the full stack featuring the
Sycamore processor and we've talked
about how we operate this complex of ice
using a custom AI and software both the
optimist and snake so thank you thank
you very much so we have time for
questions you can start with some of the
questions that have been posed and sir
one of the question is does the misc
exploration mean a detour from straight
path towards PC or are they incremental
steps pretty much lying yes so they're
they're pretty well lined I was saying
that like what you need in order to do
error correction city is large arrays of
cheapest with high fidelity operations
that you can perform reliably needs to
stay calibrated all these types of
things are pretty similar low
fundamental technology has you could
overlap that's why we chose this path
because we want to be able to explore
the new term and also they building
towards the long term I'd like to ask
one quick question among the many many
things that you had deal with you threw
in the fact that there are still TLS is
sort of an old subject in
superconducting qubits so how many how
often do you encounter relevant TLS is
among these 54 qubits
yes oh that's a great question now it's
actually a lot of the inspiration for
this frequency optimization problem like
we know that Oliver like every qubit
they have TLS defects they can couple to
and they're all it
ah yes hello Julian
since we need some quantum error
correction yeah I think so Julian you're
back yeah my micro session keeps
crashing for some enhancements though
yeah is for really some of the
inspiration for this frequency
authorization formalizing the problem
because everybody has different losses
and there are different frequencies and
they can also move and but so basically
the purpose is that we can identify them
know where they are and then we can take
frequencies to avoid them and that
actually works pretty well I would say
we see a little bit of a tail in the
distribution that's related to to us as
can move like before and after
calibration but from the performance
that we're getting that you can see that
we're doing a pretty good job of
avoiding them but not necessarily
catastrophic mm-hmm okay jump on this on
this question to ask if that's
specifically the problem with the the
54q minute which is broke it was not the
problem the presence of a DNS r1 is
broken now I just you know just it just
there's a broken line or something and
you go cool down a fridge and 54 qubits
are working and one of them doesn't want
to talk to you and that's like I see
yeah okay so maybe a last quick question
so undo yong-hwa us are you able to
perform intermediate measurements and
adaptive adaptive gates based on
classical feedback with your processor
you mean is there feedback on the
processor right now so sorry
listen if you can perform intermediate
measurements and then adopted gate
depending on the outcome of the
measurement yes that's that's the
technology has been demonstrated a wine
in the field of superconducting qubits
we're not demonstrating that here but
there's really nothing that stops us
from doing that our technology good
thank you very much
great thank you